this is the story of money perhaps the
end of money as we know it there are
some who want to kill it get rid of it
burn your dollars your Euros your Yen
and transform every penny you have into
ones and zeros digital currency entrust
it to the web and computers spread
across the planet magic internet money
it's called cryptocurrency Bitcoin
invented in secret it was a gift to the
world a potential curse on Bankers
breaking every government's grip on
money supply could it be the new gold
what's your imagination Bitcoin could be
a microeconomic miracle worker and it
could be a macroeconomic wrecking ball
is Bitcoin the currency of the future
a godsend for criminals
or a recipe for financial disaster